[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it is
the bible
the word of god welcome to bible answers
live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
the only significant land on our planet
that is not owned by any other country
is antarctica antarctica is covered by
90 percent of the world's ice and that
ice
also represents 70 percent of all the
fresh water in the world
as strange as it might sound antarctica
is essentially
a desert the average yearly total
precipitation is about two inches
and although completely covered with ice
all but 0.4 percent
antarctica is the driest place on the
planet with an absolute humidity
lower than the gobi desert how odd
that the biggest desert in the world
would also contain the most
fresh water did you know the bible says
there's a day coming when the deserts of
the world will be converted
into lush gardens stay with us friends
we're going to learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
welcome listening friends to bible
answers live if you have any bible
questions we'd invite you to give us a
call it is a free phone call we have
lines open
and really good chance if you give us a
call now you will get your
question on tonight's program the number
is 800
god says that's 800-463-7297 we'll bring
your question into our studio
not only can you listen on this radio
station but we are streaming on facebook
and that would be both the doug
batchelor facebook account
the amazing vax amazing facts facebook
account
as well as on youtube if you go to the
amazing facts youtube channel
you can also watch and we we're kind of
we've moved into a new studio
and we're getting acclimated here and
soon we're going to be broadcasting this
on a number of christian channels as
well
and my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross good evening friends and
pastor doug as always we like to start
the program with prayer
dear father we thank you that we have
this opportunity to be able to open up
your word and study
we thank you for the technology that
allows us to communicate the gospel to
those who are listening wherever they
might be father we ask you a blessing
upon the program be with those who are
listening and guide us all into a
clearer understanding of the bible
and we ask this in jesus name amen amen
you know pastor i know that you like
stories dealing with different explorers
and adventurers that
went to far-off places and one of the
areas of
exploration very popular in the early
1900s was
down to the antarctic it was a place
that very few people had actually gone
to and some great stories like
shackleton and others who
tried to actually not only go to the
antarctic but actually travel
across the antarctic and some days some
were not successful
but it's a very interesting place you
think of cold and you think of ice and
snow
but you don't always think of it as
being dry
yeah if you're going to go down there
you better take your hand cream and your
chapstick because they say the air is
extremely dry it'll dry out your lips
and your skin very quickly
and of course the coldest temperatures
ever recorded on the planet i think it
was like 120 degrees below zero
fahrenheit um are in antarctica
but it is technically it's a desert but
it sits on top of miles of frozen fresh
water and i think in some places it's
two miles
thick the ice if you can imagine that
and
it makes me think about those promises
in the bible many of them from the book
of isaiah
that in the earth made new there will be
no barren
wilderness there'll be no desert i'll
just cite a few of them here
isaiah 35 1 and verse 6 the wilderness
and the wasteland shall be glad for them
and the desert shall rejoice and blossom
as the rose for waters will burst forth
in the wilderness
and streams in the desert isaiah 41 19
and i'll plant in the wilderness the
cedar and the acacia tree the myrtle and
the oil tree
i'll set in the desert the cypress tree
the pine and the box tree together
these are trees that required you know
moisture and then the
the best one that's the clearest is
isaiah 51 3
for the lord will comfort zion he will
comfort all her waste places
he will make glad her wilderness like
eden and her desert
like the garden of the lord joy and
gladness will be found in it
thanksgiving in the voice of melody
so when the lord first created our world
it was not you know there were not these
extremes that all
kind of happened after the environment
was distorted following the flood
they were not these extremes where it
was burning hot
or freezing cold like antarctica or the
sahara desert
but the whole planet was you know a
beautiful garden
and the garden of eden was the center
and it was especially beautiful
but god is going to make a new heavens a
new earth and it talks about it being
filled with
beautiful trees and friendly animals and
it will be a paradise
and friends this is not pie in the sky
by and by
this is a very real place and god's
design that you can be there
if you'd like to know about the home of
the saved
we have a free offer we have a book the
book is called heaven
is it for real and that is our free off
this evening we'll be able to send that
to anyone who would just call
and ask for it if you're in north
america the number is 800-463-7290
that is our studio phone line here if
you have a bible question
the resource phone line is 800-835-6747
and again you can just ask for that book
it's called heaven is it for real i know
we have some who are listening outside
of north america
you can also read the book by just going
to the website amazingfacts.org or dot
com
we have a free library and you can click
and download the book and you'll be able
to read heaven
is it for real well pastor we're ready
to go to the phone lines we've got
anthony
listening in new york anthony welcome to
the program
uh good evening pastors how are you this
evening doing well
thank you and your question
um my question is it comes from a
numbers chapter 20 verse 11.
um and my question is basically if
god did not want moses to strike the
rock the second time
why did he still allow water to come out
because my thought is is that
you know if if he struck the rock and no
water came out
i think it would have prevented the
people from believing that moses was the
reason for
their blessings or even the problems
that they had and they would see that
he had no power in and of himself and i
think it would probably have negated
you know the reason for moses to be
forbidden to go into
the the holy city right so you know
we mean the holy land yes the holy land
yes
um you know if you look in verse 8 the
same chapter and god spoke to moses
saying
take the rod in your uh take the rod
you and your brother aaron gather the
congregation together
speak to the rock see he has he had
struck the rock once
years earlier a symbol of christ being
smitten for our sins which
jesus is not to be smitten a second time
for our sins or a third time
so god didn't even tell him to hit the
rock he said just take your rod it was a
sign of his power
he used the rod in his hand whenever he
did any of the miracles
he lifted up his rod before the sea
parted and so forth
but he said speak to the rock and moses
it's not just that he struck the rock
but he lost his temper before the people
he said here now ye
rebels must we bring water for you out
of this rock so it was like
they were taking credit now god honored
them
now keep in mind god sometimes gives
people
power and blessings and they could abuse
that samson had special strength
and he not only used that strength to
fight the philistines the enemies of god
he used the strength to escape when he'd
spent the night with a a shady lady
you know he tore the gates off and got
out of the city
so sometimes these gifts were given
and then you know they could be abused
now balaam was a prophet but he abused
this game yeah and absolutely
children of israel needed water at this
point prior to that as you mentioned
past the day the water came from the
rock as they wandered for those 38 years
up to this point
in the wilderness they had gone close to
the borders of the promised land
the water stopped coming from the rock
it was god's purpose that
they would have faith to enter in but
because of unbelief they ended up
having to detour around the land of edom
and they didn't have any more water so
they did need water they began to murmur
and
it's interesting here that moses and
aaron after being so faithful
so many times right at the end it seems
as though they
they took the credit for themselves
instead of pointing the people to christ
you know i remember and just one more
thought on this anthony i remember
talking to a gentleman he said you know
i went to an evangelistic crusade
and the evangelist you know told me if i
prayed and accepted christ and
my life would change and he says i
prayed i accepted christ my life was
changed and then he later heard that
that evangelist
was living a double life and the lord
answered his prayer in spite of the the
vehicle
and in the same way moses and aaron
disobeyed but the people had been
praying for water so god answered their
prayer as john was saying
does that help at all anthony no it does
help a lot and and just to see that it
wasn't just
only him striking the rock but the
manner in which he did it as well
that helps me understand better so thank
you for that all right thanks so much
for your question
all right we've got jamie listening in
minnesota jamie welcome to the program
hi uh good evening pastor dean
uh my question has to do with jesus and
uh was
jesus born spiritually blind or did he
have
spiritual sight from conception and
the there's a verse isaiah 7
verse 15 that i i come back and i look
at and i think is this
the answer to that question
where it says curds and honey he shall
eat that he might know to refuse the
evil and choose the good
is that the verse you're talking about
yeah uh
well the this verse here curds and honey
that is talking about the best of the
milk it takes the cream to make the
curds
and honey is you know the land of milk
and honey but there are also curds and
honey are symbol for the word of god
the bible says desire the sincere milk
of the word and the law of the lord is
compared to honey
and so it's saying in his mouth would be
the word
the richest word it wasn't just the word
of a prophet it was the word of the
messiah
and jesus was really nursed on the word
you know he was fed by his mother
not only naturally but i think he
learned the word at her knee
so by the time he's 12 he was able to
confound and mystify
the wise men in the temple with his
questions and answers
okay so he did have to learn from the
scriptures
yeah i don't think jesus learned the
bible
because of some supernatural straw that
god was pouring into him
jesus learned the bible the same way we
do
and it was brought to you know
scriptures were brought back to him by
the holy spirit just like for us but i
think he had to
read the bible you know it says when he
was
went to church when he was a young man
he in nazareth he stood up and he read
the scriptures as his custom was he went
to the synagogue on the sabbath day
so it was a custom of jesus to go to
church on the sabbath read the
scriptures
i think he had a very good memory you
know of course
an unusually sharp mind
okay hey thanks so much jamie hope that
helps a little bit
and we appreciate your questions you
know just one verse on that pastor i was
actually looking up while you're talking
luke chapter 2 verse 52
talking of jesus says he increased in
wisdom and stature and in favor with god
and man
so there is a growth in wisdom or
understanding or knowledge so as jesus
grew older
he understood more and more of the
scriptures and we believe somewhere
around the age of 12 when he went to the
temple
he began to understand more of his
mission and what a revelation that must
be because he said to his parents
i must be about my father's business and
he was talking about his heavenly father
right and he grew in stature because he
ate well so it was natural food that
made him grow in statute
and as a word of god to make him grew
and grown wisdom the fear of the lord
is beginning of wisdom all right we've
got brett in chattanooga tennessee brett
welcome to the program
hello pastors uh how are you doing today
doing well
thank you for calling you for taking my
uh
call so uh my question is
the the job i'm going for in the
military
or trying to go for if it's lord's will
is a search and rescue job
but i'm also trained to
handle a weapon because i'm you might be
uh
deployed to a combat zone and stuff
and my question is about the sixth
commandment i believe it is
thou shalt not murder and
uh like if i have do i hope and pray
the day never comes but if i have to
take someone's life in the military
like is that like self-defense or
something like that because i know in
the biblical times like there was
god's people uh had wars and different
things
right you know um i'll just
be very honest with you that is a tough
question because
on one hand there's no question that a
nation needs an army
to protect its freedom and its rights
uh it is true that if if a soldier
in in fulfilling his duties
must take life and he's following orders
he's not considered a murderer
but at the same time you know jesus said
those that live by the sword will die by
the sword and so
christians typically take a a pacifist
view when a christian needs to enter the
military to serve his country um
they often say you know i'd like to take
a position where
i can be saving life and as you said not
discharge a weapon
you know the story of desmond doss
yeah i actually i love that movie uh
i actually as i was watching it i kind
of
had that's what made you think about
that
yeah like i like not that i might do
what he did but i might do something
along
those lines like saving people like that
right
yeah and by the way he was a friend of
mine his
second wife was a member of a church i
pastored and so we got a chance to get
to know him great guy yeah
and then there's also um there's some
other stories you know there's a
testimony book by uh terry johnson
and um and others who have said you know
i'm i want to serve my country
i'm so thankful for the freedoms that we
enjoy i would prefer not to have a
position where i
have to make that moral choice of
pulling the trigger oh the other book is
frank hustle
a thousand must fall this man he was in
germany
amazing story and he was pressed into
the the
army and he refused to carry a weapon
what he did is he carved a gun out of
wood so he would never be tempted he
kept a wooden pistol in his holster
through the entire war and he never had
to draw it and no one ever found that it
was wood
it's quite a story a thousand may fall
is the name of it but
you know everyone has to make that
decision for themselves uh
one of the problems when you enter the
military
for christian is you lose a certain
amount of your freedom to say this is my
day of worship
and you know this is how i'm going to
spend my time you really are
surrendering
i went to military school first when i
was five years old and then two more
years between 11 and 13
and that was just military school and
you are really
at the beholden of someone else to tell
you how you're going to spend your time
so you don't get to make a lot of free
choices in the military
but you know david was certainly in the
military and
the bible tells us john the baptist the
soldiers came and said what do we do
and he gave them advice he didn't say go
away
so there's certainly a place for that
that sounded like sort of a roundabout
answer but it's a tough question
yeah i don't know if that helped you at
all
yeah i did thank you all righty thanks
so much bret appreciate your call
all right we've got paul listening in
arkansas paul welcome to bible answers
live
good evening pastors how are you doing
well how are you
oh i'm good so i was listening to a
pastor today and he was teaching
preaching
on salvation uh you know once you're
you have truly received the spirit then
uh
your sins are forgiven and you do have
eternal life
um i understand and then you mentioned
about a few other things but towards the
end
and i don't know if i interpreted his uh
his uh uh lesson correctly but
he was saying that even though we're
saved uh and we
will go to heaven we can experience a
second death
and he said that second death would be
during the uh
the 1000 year of millennium reign where
when we stand
before to be judged whether once we were
saved what did we do with our time
it's not about good work you know you
know uh
earning but you know did we uh where we
involved in the ministry
did we share the attributes of love and
writing or
did we just you know uh say hey you know
it is what it is so you know let's just
uh you know uh
go through life and he said the second
death would be that we would not
reign or uh rule over in the millennium
but uh actually
uh be cast it out and and and
and i don't know if i heard that right
but i never heard a second death
yeah let me uh jump in here first of all
you know i don't want to
specifically comment on a particular
pastor sermon because you always want
all that in context but
no saved person is going to experience a
second death
with the exception of people like
lazarus who
he died and jesus rose him and then he
died again from old age or sickness
and he'll be raised again but generally
speaking
um the the believers they may die in
natural death but they will not die the
second death and many believers in the
last days when jesus comes they don't
die even a first
death because they are transformed and
they are caught up to meet the lord in
the air like elijah they just are
translated
but no believer will die the second
death
you know i heard the pastor say one time
if you're only born once you die twice
but if you die twice
i'm getting that right if you're if
you're born once you're going to die
twice but if you're born twice you die
once there you go so you got to be born
again
right and then you only die maybe the
first death
you know i think the verse that you're
referring to there uh talking about the
second death and you'll find this in
revelation chapter 21 verse 8
it makes it clear as to who receives the
second death it says the cowardly the
unbelieving the abominable the murderers
the sexually immoral the sorcerers the
idolatrous
and all liars shall have their part
which burns with firing brimstone which
is the second death so it's quite clear
that this is the final judgment that
comes upon the wicked
that of course occurs at the end of the
1000 year period that we read about in
revelation 20.
yeah exactly so i hope that helps a
little paul does that make sense
yeah you know i i never heard before
about a second death except for those
who don't believe of course you know uh
but uh
like i said maybe i interpreted uh his
message wrong but
i figured well here's sunday and uh
you're on the air and uh called several
times and you always uh
i've given uh honest scriptural uh uh
answers so god bless you guys well thank
you sure appreciate that paul
you have a good evening you know we do
have a study guide talking about the
thousand years called a thousand years
of peace
it's about revelation 20 and the
millennium we'll send it to anyone who
calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line
and you can just ask for the study guide
it's called a thousand years of peace
we'll get that in the mail and send it
to you we've got kirk listening in
canada kirk welcome to the program
hello good night i'm pastor evening
how can we help you yeah i have a
question um gamble in terms of gambling
gambling is
wrong according to the bible right
correct
okay um just wondering in terms of
investment in stock and bonds because
gambling is basically putting in money
with
expecting a higher rate of return right
well yeah but i wouldn't put i would not
put gambling in the same category as
investing in a stock and uh
do you want me to share with you what i
think the uh the reason is
sure all right in in business everywhere
business people will invest in an idea
or a business
and as the business prospers they're
lending their money to the business to
in
to you know trade and they get a
percentage of the income
even jesus said in the parable of the
talents he said to the
the lazy servant he says at the very
least you could have invested my money
with
the bankers and what banks do is they
usually invest in stocks or businesses
and at my coming i should receive my
money with interest
gambling is you're not really investing
in anybody's work
you're not investing in productivity
what you're wanting to do
is basically you want to win at the
expense of everyone else
losing purely based on chance
now it is true that there is some risk
involved in business
if you're a farmer there's risk involved
anything really you know any business
you're involved there's always risk you
can't name
it doesn't matter if you're a doctor or
carpenter there's risk involved
in your job so we're not talking about
that kind of risk we're talking about
uh trying to get something for nothing
and i think when it comes to the stock
market in particular there are different
ways that one could
invest in the stock market some would be
more on the gambling side where
people are putting large amounts of
money in a particular stock and then
watching it and then
taking the money out and putting the
money back in and they call it day
trading going yeah
up and down speculative trading that's
right and the goal for that is just to
make money but
there is a type of investment where it's
long term and it's pretty
it's pretty solid yeah and
so i i do think there's a difference uh
you know the bible says that
um you know god rewards work
and then there's a verse in proverbs and
i forget that verse but it says uh
those that make haste to be rich will
not be innocent
and what's happening when someone's
playing a slot machine or poker or a
lottery they're trying to get rich quick
without work and without the thinking
and investment or without time and
waiting
um and that i think and you know the
other thing is you just look at the
fruit
in gambling um
people often get addicted uh some people
lose their retirement they lose their
families
they lose their home and you know we're
here in sacramento not too far from reno
and we
we've met people before of course you
don't have to go to reno anymore they
got bingo
parlors bingo casinos
so people lose a lot of money it's very
sad
all right well thanks for your your call
kirk we've got uh tassie listening from
canada tassel tessie welcome to the
program
oh yes good evening pastors and
i have a question yes
this question is i i got two questions
but i don't know if you don't have time
to
uh you to answer them all but anyway my
first question is
why jesus being called the son of david
when jesus himself said in matthew 22 45
if david then calls him lord how he see
his son
yeah that's a good question it's it's
interesting i think we had that question
with our after students yesterday
and that's talking about when and it's
psalm
that that is actually jesus is referring
to one of the psalms
when uh he asked that and let me see
here i think i've got it right at my
fingertips
um yeah the lord said to my lord at
psalm 110 verse 1
and the lord said to my lord sit at my
right hand till i make your enemies your
footstool
if jesus is the lord of david then how
could he also be the son of david
well jesus is the lord of everybody but
he came into the world as a man
he was a descendant of the line of david
jesus is the creator of all life and yet
he
was the son of mary and joseph so
you know it's just basically saying it's
interesting how the creator
in the incarnation became a creation
and there's two parts of of christ's um
humanity well
one hand you have his humanity on the
other side you have his divinity
jesus said before abraham was i am so
jesus
existed long before um in his
pre-incarnation
way back throughout all eternity and
then he took upon himself humanity
became
you know a man so depending upon what
aspect of christ you're referring to his
humanity or his divinity
that would give you a time frame
absolutely
so he tests you know i appreciate your
your question we are coming up on our
mid-time breaks we might have to budget
that to one question tonight
listening friends don't go anywhere in a
few minutes we're going to be back with
more bible questions and if you want to
call in with your question
the number is 800-463-7297 to bring your
question into the studio
i might also mention that all week long
amazing facts has
programming available and if you go to
the amazing facts website that's simply
amazingfacts.org
you're going to find there is a
kaleidoscope a virtual tree of life of
information
don't go anywhere coming back with more
bible questions
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy
study bible the updated hardcover
version is available at its lowest price
ever
and includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature and much more
call us at af bookstore to learn more
about it at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on bible answers live
order your copy today at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past alexander
the great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy 150 years in
advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question
answered provides a clearer picture of
god and his plan to save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800 4637
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and some of you may be
tuned in along the way this is a live
international interactive bible study
we've been doing this for about 25 years
every sunday night programs are replayed
around the country
and we're broadcasting live on satellite
radio as
well as many land-based stations and on
the internet and now friends
we want you to do us a favor we're doing
a few pilot programs in our new studio
before we go on tv
and we invite you to go and take a look
at what's happening as well as taking a
listen
and you can look and see by going to the
amazing facts youtube channel
you can also go to the amazing facts
doug batchelor i'm sorry the doug
batchelor facebook
page is it the doug batchelor youtube
channel too i think i forget which one
it is
you have to look and tell me both yeah
yeah and it's the amazing facts facebook
pages
as well and so we we're in our new
studio that was recently constructed
and we're kind of getting things all set
up technically for doing this
live on television on sunday evenings i
am doug batchelor my name is john ross
and we're going to go to the phone lines
we've got jason listening in canada
jason welcome to the program welcome to
the program
hi can you hear me we do and i think you
may have had your radio on your radio
turn it down awesome yeah let me put
that different
okay um yeah you know my question was
i'm gonna put this on speaker
my question was um you know how do you
feel about
uh present truth like a more present
truth that hasn't been revealed
in the 1800s or in the bible times
and also major prophets too in these end
times
um because i i truly believe that i'm
one of them
and i have tons of things out there um
jason joanne
on like tik tok and youtube and stuff
but anyway so that was my question
is how do you guys feel about present
truth
now you said you feel you're a prophet
yeah
yeah and i'm i'm like why do you yeah
well why do you think you're a prophet
you know i've been into the adventist
teachings in truth for a long time
and um i literally have dreams and i
have
um a lot of things that i put together
and talked to i've been talking to
a massive amount of people even um
amazing facts i've promoted for a long
time
but um you know i really feel god's
spirit working in me for a long time and
i've had
stealing experience and um you know i
really
feel like jason have you looked through
the i'm just wondering and i'm not
denying you know i believe there are
going to be prophets in the last days
but
you have to you know the bible also says
there'll be false prophets so you've got
to be real careful when someone says i'm
a prophet they're basically saying god
has given me a message that
you know meets that criteria um do you
know what the
eight or ten i think there's eight or
ten criteria
for determining if a prophet is a true
prophet do you know what they are
you know of course living a clean life
you know like the 144 thousand are
no guile in their mouth they're not
defiled with other churches
other doctrines and things and you know
and i
i believe that there's other prophets in
the music industry that are speaking
in symbolism and i believe there's lots
of teachers in the music industry but i
believe bob dylan is when we look at the
symbolism and actually examine the words
that he's saying
and he doesn't use hypnotic beats and
and rhythms and things like this
and he really explains a lot of stuff
in great detail of things that are
coming and i think some go
and forth too but um you know i i truly
believe there's a lot coming
well i'll tell you what tonight
everything is going to be counterfeited
jason the devil hat
yeah you know what i'd like to do i'd
like to send you
our study guide and i'll i'll answer
your question but just before i forget
we have a study guide on what are the
criteria there's about
i think it's eight or ten points that
how do you determine
if there's a true profit because in the
last days we know there'll be many false
prophets i believe there'll be true
prophets
i think but for every true prophet
there's probably 10 false ones
and i'd like for you to know to start
with what are those criteria
and but yes you know no question that
the gift of prophecy and you look at
first corinthians 14 is one of the gifts
of the church
if you look on sunday morning through
the tv channels you're going to see a
lot of
different pastors say let's say the lord
i've got this prophecy and they
they'll they'll declare right and left
they're declaring their prophecies there
were a lot of
evangelicals that were prophesying about
the election
and see about 75 percent were wrong okay
uh so you we've got to be careful about
listening to everybody that says they've
got the gift of prophecy
you know the study guide you're
referring to pastor it's a great read
for anyone it's called
does god inspire astrologers and
psychics
and it actually lists the biblical tests
for the true gift of prophecy
and we'll send it to anyone who calls
and asks the number to call for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the study
guide
does god inspire astrologers and
psychics we'll
get it get that in the mail and send it
to you all right hey thank you
jason appreciate that we've got ruth
listening in texas ruth welcome to the
program
hi hi um
my bible question well my question
is does how many
jewish laws were broken the friday
that jesus was crucified
well let me think now and and uh
it it wasn't just jewish laws but uh
i think for one thing they broke the law
when they tried christ
that um they weren't supposed to have a
trial at night
um so that was one um they
they falsely condemned him and so they
they uh perjured meaning they lied
and they found witnesses that will lie
um
the high priest rent his garment and
he's never supposed to do that
they didn't have a full sanhedrin for
the trial they left out some of those
who were
friendly towards christ like nicodemus
yeah so yeah they and then it went on
and on throughout the whole day
the way they approached the whole trial
of jesus yeah some of the laws were
um were probably not just jewish laws
but it was
a very unjust uh even by their own
standards it was a very unjust law
but i hope that does that help a little
bit
ruth yes it does okay
well thank you how old are you do you
mind my asking
um no i'm 12. you're 12. well i'm glad
you're
you're thinking deeply asking questions
like that you're making pastor
ross and i scratch our minds and go let
me see how many laws were broken
but they they definitely broke some of
their laws and uh
we thank you for your question you know
ruth and all those who are listening
that might have
young people we do have a set of lessons
geared for
young people for anyone from 7 8 9 10 11
12 that age it's called
amazing adventure and you can go to the
amazing facts
website to find out more about that just
look up amazing adventure and it's a
great set of lessons
all right we've got julie listening from
oregon julie welcome to the program
hi thank you thank you yeah
so uh my question is first timothy
chapter 4 verses 3
and 4. all right can i
read that for people listening certainly
all right it says and you know i
probably ought to back up a little bit
just to give the context
and it says in first timothy chapter
four now the spirit speaks expressly
saying that in the latter times some
will depart from the faith
giving heed to deceiving spirits and
doctrines of devils
speaking lies in hypocrisy having their
own conscience seared with a hot iron
now here's verse 3
forbidding to marry and commanding to
abstain from foods which god created to
be received with thanksgiving
by those who know and believe the truth
for every creature of god is good and
nothing to be refused if it's received
with thanksgiving for it's sanctified by
the word of god in prayer
so what particular part are you
wondering about there julie
okay so um
i'm kind of wondering about the word
creature
it says for every creature of god is
good
um are you wondering if that means every
creature can be eaten
yeah and also um
yeah every creature i mean that human
beings are creatures
and pigs are creatures and i just was
wondering about
um what that meant yeah paul is speaking
to a specific
problem that was a great uh controversy
in the early church
the jewish christians the jews who
accepted christ were telling the gentile
christians
that they could not eat animals
that had been offered to pagan uh gods
and uh paul was saying look you know if
if you want to eat that chicken a sheep
or goat that was sacrificed in the
temple of jupiter it doesn't really
matter you didn't offer it to a devil
you're asking god the blessed and then
he says
these are the creatures that are
sanctified by the word of god so right
there we know there are some creatures
that you are not according to the word
of god to eat
you are not to eat any unclean animals
but there are some that were sanctified
god said you can eat these and by prayer
and so if a creature is going to be
clean for food it must be sanctified by
the word of god
approved and and you'll find that list
in leviticus
uh or by prayer you know another way you
can translate the word sanctify there in
first timothy four verse five
is just simply set apart it comes from
the same root word so
uh for it is set apart by the word of
god
well what meats are set apart by the
word of god well that would only be the
clean animal so
again paul is not saying here that you
can just eat anything because you're
right creatures is a very broad category
could include all kinds of things but
here it sets them apart by the word of
god
and furthermore there is a church during
the dark ages
that forbade its priests from marrying
it says commanding to not to marry and
to abstain from foods that god created
to be received
some foods were not created to be
received somewhere for instance you
could eat fish
there's certain fish you could eat but
this church says you can't eat it except
certain days of the week or
something like that and so it's pretty
clear what uh
church it's talking about in this
passage hey thank you so much julie for
your question
we've got uh tj listening in oregon tj
welcome to the program
hi um my question was
uh how
like i've i've seen these videos of
these like pastors healing people
and i just wanted to know like
how is it possible that i i too can just
like be a healer i want to know how can
i become a healer like
what i've seen all right well
uh you know i don't think that there is
a um a ten part course that you can
take online so that you can be a
biblical healer
i believe that every christian is able
to pray
for healing for themselves or for
someone else
jesus told the disciples that you know
if someone in their church is sick
they can call for the elders of the
church and those are people of you know
usually age and experience that are that
meet the biblical conditions for being
an elder
and they would come and they would pray
for that person anointing them with oil
now some of the healings that you see on
the typical television channel
some of that is bamboozling circus
uh shenanigans and it's not all for real
uh you know i do believe in the power of
prayer i do believe in miraculous
healing
uh i don't think you're gonna see any
prophet of god going around with a
business card that says you know pastor
smith
healer
i i think you know as a person is
sick and they're presented to believers
some people have
gifts of healing the bible talks about
uh through faith
but um there's not really a course that
you take and we can't say
do point abc and you'll be a healer well
you know we have that verse and i think
you refer to it in james chapter 5
14 where we have instructions given if
anyone is sick let them call for the
elders of the church let them pray over
him anointing him with oil
in the name of the lord now this type of
faith healing that you see on tv
usually it's it's a big gathering it's
sort of for a show but that's not really
following the council that we find given
to us
in the bible james is quite clear what
one needs to do if they are sick
call the local elders of the church
invite them to come pray
anointing with oil confessing sins you
don't see a lot of confessing of sin
and the elders gathering for prayer
it's more of a show these type of faith
healers that you see yeah
you know there's an experience in acts
chapter 8 verse 18 where there was this
gentleman named simon
and he saw how the apostles would lay
hands on people and they would receive
the holy
spirit he said i'd like to have that
power and he said here i'll give you
money
and to buy that power and peter said
your money perish with you because you
thought the gift of god could be
purchased
it's one of the gifts of the spirit and
god decides who gets what
gifts and so if you can pray and say
lord i want to know what the gifts are
that you want to give
me what gifts of the spirit and
everybody gets different
some kind of different gifts some
multiple gifts but the lord will
determine
that hey thank you tj we got a call from
sydney australia
uh fadi is listening how you going
doing great thanks for calling that's
good thank you
um question
about habakkuk chapter 1
verses 5 and 6. all right
yeah let me read this for our friends
look among the nations and watch be
utterly
astounded for i will work a work in your
days which you will not believe though
or told you for indeed i am raising up
the chaldeans a bitter and a hasty
nation
who marches through the breadth of the
earth to possess dwelling places that
are not theirs
answer your question in particular about
that did i read the right verses
yes you did um because i'm kaldi and so
i'm a syrian kaldi and i was
wondering if it's that us or someone
else referring
i think that's interesting i i i'm i'm
i'm uh
intrigued to know that um the chaldeans
were from babylon and during the time
in particular of the reign of king
nebuchadnezzar ii
most people don't even say the second
because he was the only one most people
know about
he invaded israel he conquered
jerusalem and he carried the children of
israel captive
but not only did he conquer israel he
conquered
lydia he conquered egypt and he just
swept through mesopotamia
and that's why habakkuk is saying i'm
telling you i'm raising up a hasty
nation and they're going to be
going through the land they're going to
be a judgment on the ungodliness of
these nations
and that's exactly what happened if i
understand correctly the chaldeans were
the ruling family
otherwise known as the babylonians so
you have the babylonians they speak
spoke their language but you have the
chaldeans who were the ruling family
or one of the tribes connected with that
and they spoke
chaldean and that eventually became sort
of the royal language
and we have a portion of the actual book
of daniel
which is written in chaldean
got it i thought it was americans all
that time
no yeah this is a prophecy that happened
before the babylonian captivity and the
prophecy of habakkuk came true
very vividly with the the fall of
jerusalem
and nebuchadnezzar's conquest of the
middle east appreciate your call thanks
we hope we get more from australia
appreciate your calling fadi
all right we've got uh arnie listening
from north carolina arne welcome to the
program
hi pastor doug pastor ross thank you for
taking my call uh it's based on
revelation 19
21 and i'm reading from king james
version
i says and the remnant were slain
with the sword of him that sat upon the
horse
which swore proceeded out of his mouth
and all the fowls were filled with their
flesh
my question is who are the fowls
represent
well you read other places in the bible
where whenever there was a great
battle there's often a lot of casualties
on the battlefield
even with david and goliath david said
you know today i'm going to take your
head
from you and uh you and the host of the
philistines are going to be
eaten by the birds of carrion i'm
paraphrasing here but
um and there were often there'd be so
many birds
vultures actually have an incredible
sense of smell they're like sharks of
the air they can smell anything
decomposing
for 100 miles it's amazing and
they darkened the sky after a battle
there were so many birds of carrying
that would come in
i saw a big cloud of buzzards
above a meadow and i thought what's
going on i rode down there and there was
a dead bear
and they came i never knew there were so
many buzzards in the country but they
somehow all found it
and um so there are not literally going
to be
flocks and flots of vultures and and
raptors
uh revelation chapter 19 is using some
symbolism
yes if you look at the whole context
there it's talking about the second
coming of christ here jesus described as
coming as a king
bringing deliverance for his people and
judgment upon the wicked
and the slain of the lord as we read in
other peace places will be on the earth
from one end to the other they won't be
gathered they won't be buried
and so here we kind of have that same
description as
the wicked they are destroyed and so to
speak the birds are filled with their
flesh and again it's the symbolism that
comes from a battle scene
in the old testament absolutely so thank
you arnie we appreciate your call
and we'll try and get one or two more
while the time remains here
we got uh jemima canada
richmond canada jamima welcome to the
program
hello good evening pastor dog and pastor
ross
evening and your question
my question is from the book of verse of
isaiah 40 verse 25-31
so it says those who wait on the lord
shall renew their strength they shall
mount
mount up with wings like eagles they
shall run and not be weary
they shall walk and not fame and he
gives power to the weak
and to those who have no might he
increases strength
but it says here even the youth shall
feign and be weary
and the young men shall utterly fall so
what it says here they shall run and not
be weary and they shall walk and not
faint but
why it says the youth shall faint and be
weary and the young man shall
utterly fall why would they be weary and
fall
well i think he's talking about those
that do not fear the lord
even their youth will get weary
and the faint will fall and their men
their soldiers will fall but
those who wait on the lord so it's
contrasting those who wait on the lord
with the young armies that see right now
when isaiah gives this prophecy
i've been doing a study on isaiah the
last few months
the people of judah were being
threatened by the assyrians
in the northern kingdom of israel and
they were worried about attack
and isaiah said do not be afraid of them
but even their young men
and their soldiers they're going to
they're gonna get weary and faint and
you
often had you know that's why they
recruit young soldiers they have a lot
more stamina
but he said those who wait on the lord
meaning in the nation of israel if
you're faithful
if jerusalem is faithful it says you
will mount up with wings like eagles
turns out when assyria did attack
god fought for them and
but it's also promise for god's people
through history
that god renews the strength you think
about when
elijah no no yeah elijah when
he prayed and the rain came down it says
he girded himself up he ran before
ahab's chariot
and he had like this supernatural
strength he was running and he was not
weary and he also went through the
wilderness
for 40 days and 40 nights running and
not being weary
and so god can give supernatural
strength to his people
all right well thanks for your call uh
jemima we got uh robert listening in
minnesota
uh robert welcome to the program
good evening badgers so i had a
question about where is there anywhere
in the bible where we can interpret if a
dream was
of god yeah you know
that's a good question because um you
know
you read in the bible about daniel who
had this gift of dream interpretation
and joseph who had the gift
of dream interpretation i'm trying to
think of a third i think
there are some others that interpreted
dreams but um
okay of course joseph jesus father was
given dreams but i think the angels
interpreted what they were
um usually if god's gonna give you a
dream you don't have to worry about
where's the interpretation going to come
from because if god wants you to know
he will provide either the
interpretation or an interpreter
so if you have a dream and you're
wondering was that from the lord you
just pray and say lord if that's from
you help me to understand it he may do
it by
just giving you some understanding of
what it means
or he may send somebody that has that
gift now i don't know too many people
that i've met that have the gift of
interpretation you got to be careful
about
people that say you know for 9.95 i'll
tell you what your dream means
and of course not all dreams have
spiritual significance
the bible speaks of out of the abundance
of the affairs of the day
people sometimes have dreams it could
relate to what
you've been thinking about yeah it could
relate to what you had for supper
so not all dreams are necessarily from
god that's right
a matter of fact 99.9999
of dreams are the result of your brain
defragmenting through the night the
things that you've been thinking about
and i've often find my my dreams are
somehow associated with things i was
stressing or thinking about or just
experiencing
in recent days so i hope that helps a
little
pastor ross can we get in one more
caller maybe before we
we run out of program time yes we've got
donna listening
um donna welcome to the program rhode
island thank you
thank you very much good evening
good evening thank you for calling
well thank you for taking my call um my
question
is i've been talking with someone um a
little bit about
my beliefs and my question for you is
because i haven't really been able to
tell her in the bible where it says
um about tithing yeah
and she asked if tithing was a
requirement for salvation
well here's what i would say about that
is
giving is a requirement of salvation and
it starts with giving your heart to the
lord
the the whole attitude of the christian
is god so loved the world he gave
it's one of giving you know god is a
giver
and when you give the lord your heart he
actually owns a hundred percent of you
it's like that king in the bible said
all that i am and all that i have are
yours
and when you come to the lord that's our
prayer all that i am and all that i have
is yours now one of the ways we show our
faith in the lord
is by giving a percentage of our income
100 belongs to him but he says i want
you to show your faith in me
by returning a tenth which that's where
you get the word tithe
you find that in uh leviticus in
malachi chapter three i think the
specifics of tithe is also seen
in jacob promising god a tenth if god
would bless him and bring him back
and abraham gave a tenth till
melchizedek they were to give a tenth to
the priests to support the work of god
and jesus even referred to tithe and
saying do not leave it undone
matthew 23 23 but i gotta i'm talking
fast because i can see the clock and
we've just got seconds left
hey i hope that helps a little bit donna
we do have a lesson called
in god we trust and uh if you call
800-4335 i'm sorry 835-6747
you can get a copy of in god we trust
so listening friends we are sorry but
we're out of time for tonight
we hope you've been blessed and learned
something we hope that you if you
hear it all you can go to the doug
batchelor facebook page and you can see
the program
archived there we will study his word
together god willing again
next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
[Music]
okay friends let's start with the basics
we know we're here
but we're not here for very long so the
most important thing would be
if we could learn during this life how
to live forever
this is the central focus of amazing
facts now there's a lot of wonderful
things that christian ministries do
i believe in christian education but if
the schools
lose the message of salvation you end up
with more educated sinners
i think it's very important for us to
build churches
but if the churches lose the message of
salvation they just become buildings and
shells
i think it's important to have a medical
ministry and build hospitals
but if they separate that from the
message of salvation
you just prolong a sinner's life for a
little while that's why for years
amazing facts has made it our focus to
present the saving truth
that sets people free and friends we
want to thank you for your support and
your gifts
we'll do our very best to convert those
resources into the currency of heaven
may god bless you and keep amazing facts
in your prayers
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
would you like to know god's plan for
our troubled world and solutions for
your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned and updated
amazing facts 27 bible study guides
provide straightforward bible-based
answers that are enlightening
encouraging and easy to understand
giving you real relevant bible answers
to questions like
how can i have healthier relationships
when will jesus come
and much more order yours today by
visiting afbookstore.com
or by calling 800-538-7275
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
god's word
sign up today for this free bible study
course by calling
1-844-215-7000 that's 1-844-215-7000
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
at 800-835-6747
[Music]